Bro, there's like real imminent drama about to happen though.
Okay, that's actually not good. Everybody's just like, "You know
what? That OTK or I don't even know who those people are. I don't
know who these people are. Techno, I I left. They didn't resign
me. Guys, you're so disingenuous." And Miz is like, "What about
Joelcoin?" He's like, "What about that girl's you covered up,
Miz?" There's real imminent drama coming up soon between Miz
and the rest of OTK. Miz Teone. Teone's been kind of chomping
at the bit to go after Miz if you can't tell. his he makes it
very clear to his community even when Misk was big. What are
they all distancing themselves from? Did they really Did they
really bury those Emirou grooming allegations? Is it Is this
going to come up? Did Miskip do it a second time? Hello. Hello.
Hello.
How's it going, guys?
How are we doing
today?
How we doing
How we feeling?
How we doing? How's it going? What's up? What's up? What's up,
guys? It is Wednesday, July 9th.
And we're back. Okay, we're back. We're back. We're
We're back. Hello. Uh, Scy, welcome back. Yeah, I saw you say
you hadn't been here a couple days. Welcome back.
Had a couple good streams there. Took yesterday off. Back today.
I don't know how I'm going to go through the pirate software
stuff. I know I'm going to go through it. I think I might do
the coding stuff first just because to go back through stop games.
Maybe there's I'm guessing if we look through YouTube, we'll
find a good video for Pirates Opera versus uh Ross Scott from
Stop Stopping Games because I didn't follow it. I have like all
of the stuff. I have Ross' video. I have like all the source
material. I just don't know if like I'm guessing somebody's packed
this together in like a good way so far and we could probably
just skip to that.
Uh what else is there?
You guys follow the Will Stansel stuff from yesterday and the
day before? Cuz that was crazy. Anyone know what I'm talking
about?
Anybody know? If you know, you know. Uh Will Stansel is a guy
who's like a liberal political commentator. Like a very like
an openly like central liberal commentator, right? The Stansel
stuff is so funny. There's not really a lot of content there,
but it is so funny. And I might I might actually have to go kick
only for that stuff because some of the content is so funny,
but so deranged. If you don't know, Will Stansel basically um
so Grock is an Grock going insane. All right. Is an of Grock
losing its mind, becoming super racist and super
I guess. Oh man. And basically people don't like Will Stansel.
A lot of unhinged people don't like Will Stansel. So below Will
Stansel's like complaining about it and below people started
asking for like
mega. Yes. Mega.
So below Will Stansel's posts, okay, people started asking for
like, can you write me fanfiction of Will Stansel getting like
raped? And it wrote out very graphic, very intimate details of
Will. And Will Stansel was like, I think I'm going to have to
f I'm going to think I'm going to have to file a lawsuit over
this. This is not okay. And basically everybody else is like,
dude, you're a loser. Are you actually talking about doing this?
Oh boy.
It was uh it was goofy. This seems really problematic that Grock
is talking about Elon Musk me with a rusty iron rod right now.
This is really problematic
Yeah, it's not it's not good. It's not
dude, it's uh
it's cool seeing um like the term behavior becoming a thing online.
You know, started off with just a couple little embers, right?
Started off with uh joking about leaving bruises on the back
of some guy's neck and now we're here and everybody is telling
Will Stansel that he is uh exhibiting behavior. You love to see
it. All right. You love to see it. You love to see it. See if
the Twitch is picking up at all. We're not getting viewers on
Twitch. I I'll just But um sometimes we just don't have the draw
on Twitch. Yeah, we don't have like anybody watching on Twitch.
I'm sorry Twitch watchers, okay? But like if you guys aren't
up at if you guys aren't up at like 20 30 viewers by the time
I'm at like 30 minutes, you guys are gone. So head back to kick.
Well, I'm just saying for the Twitch watchers, if you guys aren't
there, head back to kick cuz I am
I'm not going to keep that stream open for like five to 10 viewers.
I think we we we'll usually after like an hour or two have like
30 viewers on there, but even that it's like
it's like a big hit to money to keep it up to be honest. Cognitively
needs to enter the general
Uh, yeah, it does. And it will. Uh, Spruce Willis, I'm not going
to answer a question about Cherry today. Sorry, buddy. I know
you're a fan. I know you're asking from a good place. I know
you're a fan. Opportunity cost. Yeah, exactly. Cybo. Yeah. Uh,
what what could we do, though, guys? If you do listen, if you
do have Twitch Primes, though, you could have head over to
with an underscore. All right. How do you keep bouncing on? Um,
nothing but momentum. Here's here's the link right here, guys.
Yeah, you guys got primers. Go throw them over there on uh on
twitch.tv/jdk
with an underscore. There's the link in kick chat. All right.
Especially so many missed streams. Uh yeah, yeah, yeah. No, no,
no. That's that is true, though. I've missed quite a few. No
longer. Okay. No
We're maybe taking one head off a week for the next like eight
weeks or something. I shouldn't promise that, but I think so.
All right. Uh let me go. What are we What are we going to do
first? I got some I got some links. I don't know if I have anything
on the subreddit today. Yeah, there's no new subreddit posts.
So,
oh wait, there is one
which is like I'll I'll just read it because it's uh it's there
and somebody took the time to write it out. So, I feel like I'll
feel like I give it a read. Ozel, you're uh you're a bit off
sometimes, buddy. Bro, imagine this Capiche guy just joined to
try to talk [__] Imagine being like so cognitively
raped that you go to other people's streams that you don't like
to try to talk [__] when you like openly are like,
"Your stream sucks.
You're not even hate watching. You're just here to like drop
a mean message and leave.
At least I respect a hate watcher. Okay, you a hate watcher.
I respect it. You're just a random jerk off who sucks Destiny's.
I do not respect it, buddy. Okay, I don't respect it.
You are mentally. This is behavior. This is the prime example
of behavior from Capitra over here. You hate to see it. Bye-bye.
It's getting there, guy. Guys, we're It's entering the lexicon.
I'm telling you, it's entering the lexicon. You love to see it.
And it's it's on the way. Okay, let me switch over to my browser.
We'll do subreddit and then I got a couple tweets. Go through
the Grock stuff. Maybe do the Will Stencil stuff pretty early.
What do we got here? What do we got? What do we got? Oh, also
blastoff tweet, guys. Blastoff tweets. I still have it here.
I do not. Sorry. A little
at the moment, but we're getting there. Okay. I forgot to I forgot
how to stream. I took that day off. I forgot how to stream. I'm
figuring it out. I'm learning. I'm learning. I'm learning. I'm
learning. We are 12 likes away from unlocking the gen chat in
the Discord. Did you see the denim tweet? No, I did not. What
is the denim tweet? Oh, let's go, Cy. Thank you.
No, I'm saying we have not hit the requisite likes, guys. We
have not hit the requisite likes. Let me switch over to my primary
browser. Hello. There we are. Cool. All right. Here's primary
browser. And look, I think it was uh eight retweets, 25 likes.
guys
engage with the blastoff tweet. There's the links below. Okay,
we got the links. We don't even have a Twitch link in there.
We could have a Twitch link in there, but we do not today. All
right, I'm probably going to end there anyway. Sorry to the Twitch
viewers.
Uh,
Passion Accords. Pashana Accords. Yeah, you know what? You're
okay. You can stay. You can stay. You're just going to hate watch
and see and like uh and participate and like try to correct me.
That's cool. You love to see it.
Here's my money. Please wish me a happy 22nd birthday. Happy
22nd birthday between the stars. What's up? Happy 22nd birthday
to you.
Oh, by the way, we got 25 gifted right off the bat. Massive 25
gifted. Let's go. Where do I go on the tier list? I don't know,
dude.
I have no idea. I think some of the most memorable dram memorable
dramas from the past like year in that community are sourced
from me. So, you know, probably at the top. Probably at the top,
but we're not proud of that fact.
Not proud at all. Okay, I'm going to check the Twitch one more
time. I think I'm shutting it off.
There'll be other nights where we can multiream. It's not going
to be Tonight's not a multi streaming night. Okay. It just ain't
it.
Twitch off. Twitch is off. Twitch is off. Twitch is off.
You really fat IRL. Is that really you in the photo Destiny posted?
No. And No. Well, sorry. I'm like I have like a a belly IRL.
Yeah. But I I run I think I'm down to like a
What was it last I did? I'm probably a little above, but like
a 25 minute 5K.
You know, you know
the girl pouncing and screaming. Think about your views was the
best. Damn.
Uh, okay. Let me close this Twitch. Sorry to semantics. I know
you're the only one over there. I'm sorry, buddy.
Okay. Let me switch this over.
No more multireaming.
It's off.
We're here. Kick only. Okay. All right, guys. We're so good to
go. We're ready. We're here for it. Okay, we got this. We got
this. I'll read this. Uh, this was a couple days ago. It's so
JTO asked what what was Destiny's incentive for debating Kelly
and chemistry and on JTO's Discord constantly. It's partially
what JTO himself mentioned months ago, which is that Destiny's
primary PR strategy is to insult his critics, accuse them of
hypocrisy, and direct the attention of his audience toward them
instead of toward himself. He did this against Vos, Bob 7, and
Mr. Girl as well. In fact, he probably feels that wrestling around
in the mud about something like chemistry helps him trivialize
your disagreements. His goal is to make everyone seem kind of
petty, unethical, and or gross so that his audience doesn't think
he's uniquely bad. He wants to drag everyone down to his level
or muddy the waters. And he doesn't mind giving you a few views
every now and then to do it. And just like with the previous
critics, he'll keep bringing you up until he no longer considers
you a threat.
That's interesting. That was like I think that's basically true,
right? I think that was a good post. Yeah, I think that was a
pretty good post. It's also why
oh man, the whole like the whole drama cycle on the internet,
it's like uh
very interesting. There's some some deeper past past first order
thinking there that you could do. There's some interesting concepts,
interesting ethical questions about doing drama content at all.
Anyway, um I think there's not much in the subreddit right now.
I got to stream consistently and check the subreddit consistently
and then people will post again. But not much going there. How
are we doing on this tweet? I kind of wanted to wait on the blastoff
tweet to continue on with the stream, but bro, 17. We got to
go. We got to do better than that. We got to do better than that.
25 to unlock the Discord. Guys, watch my merk clips. No, I'm
good. That isn't petty to be clear. He's ruthless. Yeah, but
it's hard to be ruthless when you're arguing chemistry with Kelly
Gene while I sit there mocking the concept of even having this
discussion because you're a petty like degenerate weirdo and
then you have to listen to me mock you while Kelly Jean teaches
you about chemistry. Like you can't pick one or the other, right?
He has to sit there and listen to me make fun of him for even
entertaining this, for wasting all of his time as like a millionaire,
right? That's nice. That feels nice.
Does Nordon have a case? I don't look at weird come vampire rage
bait. Okay,
the guy sees the number slipping and he's got a tweet about dead
kids. Okay, dead dead kids in a conservative state. And then
he gets to go, "Oh no, I'm actually doing this for altruistic
reasons." Shut the up, loser.
Nobody's tweeting about dead kids for altruistic reasons. Like,
actually yourself. Not in a video game. In real life, actually
yourself.
come vampire. That's what we call destiny. Uh, let's talk about
the NordVPN tweet Ozel just posted in chat.
Anyway, what were we doing? Oh, right. And now that we're on
kick only or kicking Twitch, quick kicking Twitter only, we can
take a look at this. Oh, it's very exciting, guys. It's very
exciting. It's the anti-semite Super Bowl over here.
Nick's interview with Candace Owens drops this Friday. Nick Fuentes,
Candace Owens, finally talk. Turn this up. And I was interested
to speak to the most evil people in the world. The most evil
human in the entire world. I wanted to get the backstory for
how this human became so evil. And let me show you a trailer
for that. Oh, no, no, no, no. The tweeting about dead kids is
not evil. Trust me, it's not evil. Um, this guy has one like
a humiliation fetish. So, he wants to go on like uh different
shows and be humiliated for being like a weirdo sociopath loser.
And he
like it's just a strategy where he'll go, "No, I actually was
making a different point." Right. That's laughing at the dead
kids. No, it's about hypocrisy over the California fires. No,
it's not. They're not even analogous situations. yourself again,
loser.
Oh, gay. You actually are doing the thing. Look, you're doing
the exact thing he talked about. Yeah, that's like the goal for
like people who are too follow any argument. This is exactly
It works on you. The whole media strategy literally works on
you. Are you intentionally Did you listen to me read this and
you were like, "Oh, I'm going to pretend to be exactly the thing."
Interesting. Wow. Yeah. You did not have sponsorship opportunities
to begin with, Ozel. Don't worry about it. do the same thing
as Destiny just with a different filter. Okay.
Uh, zero engagement, zero intellect, zero brain cells.
Gone. Or you could join the Discord and come and argue, I guess,
about why I'm the same as this guy. That would be crazy.
You'd have to be mentally to think he's actually laughing at
the dead kids. Wait, why did he post that picture to was it donut
operator with the kids like arms out of the water? How is that
not just mocking dead children?
Wait, where's the nuance in that tweet? That's just a picture
of a kid drowning.
That's just objectively rage bait.
This is disgusting. Come vampire rage bait because he has a humiliation
fetish. He just wants to be humiliated and told he's a by everybody
on the internet. You understand that, right? You you couldn't
possibly be stupid enough to think that his goal is to change
anybody's mind. He just wants to be called a and a loser by as
many people as possible. That is the only goal there. Okay. Well,
it's like his primary goal. There are some secondary goals there
as well.
Oh, he did it all the time. Wait, he did it all the time. Cy,
yeah, he does it all the time. But you're a terrible person for
talking about how he has how he let his son become a Nazi who
looks like he is addicted to aderall. I've never said that Boris
Yonko in fact or Borsen Yonko in fact I disavow talking about
his kid entirely. So I disavow you. I've never said that except
while reading your message.
Many people have said that and I have not given comment because
I am above commenting on how terrible a parent he is. People
who jokes like that work on are already bought into the DG call.
Yeah, obviously. Well, it's like, dude, it could be a funny joke,
but it's not like he's not using it as a funny joke, right? He's
just been like a totally since Lauren Southern left left him,
he's been totally bitter towards all conservatives. He's like
hated them and slowly like destroyed all of his professional
relationships, right? Like slowly over time, like totally corrosive
loser behavior that cannot possibly go mainstream in any way.
You think you and Desi belong in the same work camp? Yeah, sure.
Uh, if you can name something we both did that like I've criticized
that uh people have broadly criticized.
I don't like
Okay. No, it's going to go down the the cherry thing. I'm not
going to go down that today. It's like it's so stupid that people
try to compare it. It's like not close. It's not even It's not
even slightly close.
And it's embarrassing that people can't can't open their eyes
even a little bit. God, there's just no engagement from anybody
out here. I have to deal with I get like
I I get like uh
Queenman. That's like the one person I know who actually watches
content or looks at people's statements and engages with them
critically in any way. That's like the only person I know, unfortunately.
Uh no, Maximus, no I'm not. I literally just explicitly said
no. Oh, actually Pasha, if your if your problem is just with
like streamers who provide nothing like positive to society,
then yeah, we would belong in the same work camp. Technically,
we are both guilty of that. That's That's fair. That You know
what? You actually got me on that one. That is totally fair.
Okay, let's continue on with this guy. I only did a thing
and I was interested to speak to the most evil people in the
world. The Sorry if it sounded like I was being sarcastic. I'm
not. I'm I'm going to watch this now. But I'm just like, "Oh,
if your problem is just with streamers who don't provide anything
to the world, that's like every streamer essentially. That's
totally fine. That's a reasonable criticism to have. evil human
in the entire world. I wanted to get the backstory for how this
human became so evil. And let me show you a trailer for Meeting
me, what's your impression? Do you think I'm a evil person or
I don't think you're evil. I think they're you're asking me.
I became friends with all the Daily Wire people. I said, "Why
does the United States give Israel $3.8 billion per year? You
really shouldn't ask that." They would say, "The way you're asking
it is anti-semitic." I'm just asking questions. Did that then
make you go, "Okay, no, actually I do hate Jews." Something's
up with the Zionists or Israel. It's not Israel. It is the You
You think that your ideas are going to grow with that perspective?
Well, they are. You kind of lament the fact that you've been
cancelled. You lament the fact that nobody will have your platform.
And in the very same breath, talk about being a hypocrite. You're
going after Dave Smith for what? Like, why is she doing Dave
Smith? And that's why you suck. You do have ideas that there
shouldn't be interracial marriage. I've seen those clips. Can
you explain why that is? My values are not just who I'm in love
with and things like that. It's also my heritage, my identity,
my race. For a long time, I would say I'm racialist. Now, I just
say I'm racist. Are you a Peter?
okay. Uh, it's funny. Obviously, we disavow. Okay. Obviously,
we disavow.
But it's funny when he said, "I used to say racialist. Now I'm
just Now I just say racist. That's funny. Um he has to go into
the hater thing now, right? I don't think he still goes back.
I think he goes like I don't trust He tries to do this like dance
where he'll go like I don't I just don't trust people. Like I
I don't hate people. I just don't trust them. I just don't think
they're they're working for our society. He'll say it like the
Joker. Okay. I just don't know if they're really working for
us. They seem to be working for like another country. seem to
be something of like a a third column, fifth column,
whatever number of column. I think he'll get it right though.
Okay.
Uh there's that one. I said one more tweet I was going to cover.
I might want to look into this later. Okay. If I remember correctly,
there was like some weird there's some weird about Oh, what the
was there? There was some weird where like Tech Tone or Asmin
Gold were kind of referencing Msk and OTK and I think O interpreted
as like oh is OTK gonna break up? I think that's what it was.
Okay, this guy is uh
I just don't need the argument my chat basically
with the with the tweets. You can try to do this, right? You
can try to go, "Oh, he's not talking about dead kids." But there's
a reason he's using that repeatedly over and over again, right?
He's trying to just He's trying to uh get people upset. It's
just weird come vampire rage bait. You can make the exact same
points without the dead kids, but he is not persuasive enough
or entertaining enough or funny enough or anything enough to
actually just make the points well without having to do the rage
bait. He just does the weird come vampire rage bait. Right. That's
what we're mocking. We're mocking him for the weird come vampire
rage bait. It's just lazy. It's intellectually lazy. It's It's
boring.
The script is boring, bro. Get something new. Get some new material,
loser. Anyway,
but that's that's really the criticism, the real Rammy. But you're
gonna go now because uh I just don't want people having this
argument in the chat right now. We're covering other stuff doing
other interesting things here and you can go talk about Destiny
in Destiny's chat. Good luck. Okay, Asmin Gold. Yes. So, there's
something about like Msk possibly leaving or OTK breaking up
in some way. And no, I'm not watching any other clips. I'm watching
this clip right now. If you are coming to me while I am covering
this content and asking if am I going to cover other content,
I am probably going to start timing out. Good luck. Okay, we're
covering this clip. So, there's some other clip where I I'll
try to find it at some point, but uh if somebody wants to look,
I think O tweeted it where it's like it's Asmin Gold Tech talking
about how like they're like kind of taking shots at Miskf. I
think they're all getting ready to Misk in the back. Okay,
I think Msk's got to go. That's what I think's about to happen.
I don't think they're going to kick him out of OTK. I could see
like Asmin Gold leaving OTK and maybe joining up a tecton doing
an org. Maybe like a pseudo political org. That would be totally
disgusting in every way, you know. But Asmin Gold did this little
speech today and it was kind of I listened to a little bit of
it. It was kind of weird. It was just a little weird. Didn't
Asmin already leave OTK? I think he's like stepped down, right?
But he still owns most of the shares, doesn't he? Isn't he still
like the the largest shareholder in OTK?
Can you really leave an organization if you're the largest shareholder?
It's kind of weird, isn't it?
I am
Did you cover Nick and Miskf beefing the other day? No. And that's
the thing is I wanted to see because I think I think there was
like a a narrative starting with that that I've seen some tweets
about, but I just have not been streaming consistently to pick
it up.
These possibly hold on, let me go Ozel.
Yep. The Techone one is definitely one. Asmin Gold says there
will be he'll be there to correct any misinformation when the
nukes fly between Teetone and Miskf. Yes. And I I don't think
I don't think that Asminold is going to take Miskf's side. Okay.
I don't think so. I think Msk has worn out his welcome.
If anybody's got the NMP tweets, those are those are good, Ozel.
Thank you. Those are exactly what I wanted. So, we'll listen
to this and then I'll try to work backwards and just give you
like sort of how I'm seeing it.
I I am totally in my villain arc. I'm going to say that now.
I am completely in my villain arc. I don't give a about any of
this stuff anymore. I don't care about any of this garbage. I'm
going to do whatever the I want and I don't give a [__]
And so that's it, bro. Like, yep.
Yeah. Thank Oh yeah, bro. We are crashing out. We are done. You
finally uh forgot what it means. Yes, exactly. But we'll circle
back to that. Okay. And crashing out. We're done again. Like
6 months ago.
Was it 6 months ago? Not even. Was it when he got banned? And
he was like, "Guys, I'm going to clean up my life. I was being
a really terrible person and I'm going to clean up my life and
I'm going to clean up my act and I'm going to be a good person
on the internet from now on." That lasted
like 6 months. And a true story about Cataclysm win. No, not
even that. That's too bad for that. Remember when Zach was going
to be
I will clarify that statement when the time comes.
Okay. Okay. Okay. In my head, I have a head cannon of what happened
here. I think when this happened, Asmin Gold was ready to stand
on business and tips out and Miz went to him and said, "Hey,
no, for the sake of OTK, for the sake of OTK, you have to like
fall in your sword here, okay? You got to do it." And I think
I think Msk told him to do it because Msk had to fall in his
sword over the Maya stuff, over the um Adriana Lee stuff, right?
And I think they told Asmigold, you got to fall in your sword
here. And I think he's been ever since. And that's what he's
referring to. He's like, "When the time comes, when we got this
misk rat, okay, when we got this,
then I will explain to you what happened." Okay?
Now, this is entirely schizophrenic. This is entirely my narrative
in my head. This is entirely made up whole cloth based on a few
clips that I've like absolutely just tied together. Okay, I haven't
even watched all of the clips that this is my head cannon now.
Okay. is they're getting ready to tok to knock him out of streaming
entirely to or at least get him out of OTK or or dissolve OTK
and I think they're gonna do something else. I think so.
But that that to me was like, wait, what? Your whole apology
when you're like, no, no, no. I didn't mean to actually genocide
those people. He's like, I'll tell you about why I had to make
that statement later. Maybe it really is a villain arc.
Msgif not even in OTK anymore. Oh, is he out of OTK? Well then,
hold on.
Msk speaks out about OTK joining kick. What?
Yo, there's my kick stream right now. kick.com/misk.
Youing got it, chat. I am going to kick. Yeah, clearly I am there.
I'm clearly there. I am clearly there. Let me make myself very
clear.
Oh, OTK will be producing a few events on Kick this year for
Kick Studios. Those select events will be on kick. The streamers
will continue to stream on platforms they choose to foster their
communities. You said the same thing in more words semantics.
Oh, was this that like OTK was going over to kick? Not going
to kick.
Period.
Exclamation mark play.
I will not go to
Period. Exclamation point. Play.
That's it. That's all you need to know. I will not go. Why? Because
train wrecks totally you in every way and you actually get PTSD
at the thought of being on the same platform as him. Is that
like the reason? Like literally just PTSD from train wrecks utterly
obliterating you in every possible way. Is that is that what
you mean? I think that's what he means. Yeah. Only reason why.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. Does she waffle? Okay. Literally I
didn't say anything special there. We all know exactly what it
is for Miskf. We all know exactly why nobody wants to be on the
uh the same platform as him or sorry, we know exactly why he
doesn't want to be on the same platform as other people. We know.
We 100% know.
Everyone knows the train wrecks tweet on him is iconic. Well,
the set of tweets is iconic. It's like you miss, you're such
a
you're so disingenuous. And M is like, "What about Joltcoin?"
He's like, "What about that girl's you covered up, Miz?" It's
Train Wreck. Train's embodying the uh
embodying the you know, send one of ours to the hospital. will
send one of theirs to the morg. He was just like, "Yeah, you
want to you want to go?" "Yeah, I'm ready. I've been waiting.
I've been waiting for you, Miz. I've been waiting." Ms. Keif
said he Well, we're watching the the clip. We'll just see what
he says. I've had times where I thought about it. I've had times
where I think about it. He went to Rumble, by the way. He went
to Rumble with like Nick Fuentes. I wonder I wonder if he'd mentioned
racist being on kick. You can't do that when you took a Rumble
contract, bro. You can't do it. Can't do it. Their owner made
me try to kill myself. I will not go to kick. Which owner? Wait,
which owner? It's definitely train, right? Their owner.
What if Miz has worked this all the way to the top and he thinks
it's like Eddie? Like like he doesn't just mean train. He actually
means Eddie. Like Eddie set up a conspiracy to make Miz want
to kill himself. It's definitely train. But I've had times where
I thought about it. I've had times where I think about it. Their
owner made me try to kill myself. I will not go to kick. I'm
good. Okay. So, actually we just we actually predicted it. It
wasn't complicated. It wasn't difficult. I've not seen anything
around this, but it just popped up on my screen on my screen.
Yeah, it is actually behavior again. We've seen it. We've seen
it multiple times today already. It just keeps happening. That's
it. Period.
Can other people go? Go for it. I understand how the world works.
Go make your money. Go do your thing. Go live life. I don't care.
Go to kick. Do whatever you want. I don't blame streamers for
ever going to kick. Go for go for it. You want to make money?
That's what this job's for. Me personally. Not about it. I can't
do it. Wouldn't do it. Wouldn't do it. Do it, Miz. It's not about
morals. It's not about anything else.
That's just it.
It's not about morals. It's not about anything. It's not about
making a statement. It's not about anything like that. I just
have a vendetta against this. Okay, that's it. Train wrecks.
That's my only policy in life. Okay. Millions of dollars, no
thank you. Train wrecks. Millions of dollars? No thanks. Train
wrecks. That you. No way. I would literally want I would never
live with myself. Period. Now, will I make less money because
I'm out there? Absolutely. Which means you guys get more subs.
Who am I kidding? That KCIP stuff, you guys can't compete. We
ain't making anything close to the That's not true, guys. We
only have 400 viewers here. Okay. That's not true. what he just
said. Not true. All of your donations make a massive difference
in my life. Okay? If you want to fight off future homelessness,
feel free to donate to the stream, okay? You can gift a sub on
kick. You could throw your Twitch Prime at me. You can uh you
can buy a TTS message. Exclamation point. Donate in the chat.
That will give you these sites where you can donate. Okay? Uh
whoops. Whoops. Whoops. Didn't pin that pin in Kickbot. $2 minimum
on Kickbot. $3 minimum on Streamlabs. If you like Streamlabs,
use that. If not, use Kickbot. I make less money off of Kickbot,
but there's AI voices. You get to be funny. Okay. I'd prefer
you homeless actually. Well, that's very rude. What would you
do for entertainment? Mugwumps.
What would you do exactly? Why does he have a poster Frogan?
That's an excellent question.
That is an excellent question.
Damn. Up next to the N64 cases. That's crazy. Have you considered
homelessness could build your character? No, I have not. What's
your thoughts on the Fearbuck stuff? I have no idea what you're
talking about, Rhox.
talking about the fact that Fearbuck like is an Aiden Ross community
member like Dick Sock or is there something else?
You gota give me links. I've not been plugged in the past couple
days. Okay, I stream but it's like I literally I go like an hour
before my stream. I collect the links I need to tell one story
and then I go live. Okay, it's been uh bare bones budget for
the past week or so. Not super plugged in. You got you got an
idea of what you're talking about? Send it to me. I'll check
it out.
Keeping you on the brink of homelessness motivates you to stream
more. That's true. Shut it down. Yes. Was the feared buck tweet?
Oh Jesus. I should not pull this up before I see Oh, I'm pretty
sure YouTube has clarified this. Yeah, they clarified it again
here. This references a minor update to our YouTube partner program
policies. Channels using AI to improve their content can still
monetize if they follow our policies. Our reused content policy
hasn't changed. So, it's like it's not going to be I don't even
think this is going to apply to React content,
right? Hold on. What is this? Don't just link the full policy
thing,
Uh policy was better identify when content is mass-produced or
repetitive.
So like this is just going to be if they think you're using like
AI enhanced content to like an insane extent that it's like really
not like this will be like Jordan Peterson Sigma affirmations
videos. That's what's going to get dinged. Okay. No more Jordan
Peterson Sigma affirmations video. No more no more Jordan Peterson
reading like Bible passages to you. You're going to do these
like AI voiceover things. Yeah, you don't make that content.
You
Yeah, it's always been like this. It has. I don't think anything
I don't think like react content is going to get dinged at all.
Yeah. Anyway, this was Yeah, this was answered back previously.
So, GG. It's also for those meme channels that just put together
a bunch of clips into one video and then upload it multiple times.
Oh, I didn't I'm unaware of this. I'm sure people find different
ways to farm the YouTube algorithm. farm YouTube for for ad revenue
different uh crazy ways. You basically just described Sniperwolf,
by the way, just so you know. The money they make over there.
Let's just get that out of the way. They make way more than we
do. We are we are broke boys compared to those guys. But that's
okay, you know? I mean, like I make enough money. I don't need
to go do that. You know, I understand that people want to. Um
and don't get me wrong, I've I've I've tried to see deals. I've
tried to see offers, but I just know myself at the end of the
day that like I wouldn't go there. Like I know mentally I would
[__] hate my life. And unless you're going to pay
me an obscene amount of money to go there like, "Hey, this is
so stupid. I can't say no." Um, I wouldn't go over there. I just
wouldn't. It'd have to be something like, "Dude, listen. Train
wrecks. That guy tried to get me to myself." But also like $3
million a year, $5 million a year. I mean, I could be convinced.
Yeah, Chad. Someone throws me like $20 million a year. I'll get
20 mil. I'll let you guys know. I'll put I'll say, "Hey, look,
it's going to be tough three years. I'll see you guys in three."
You know, I'll give you guys each a buck. But wait, wait, wait.
20 mil in three years. That's pretty close to what I said. Yeah,
Chad. If someone throws me like $20 million a year, we have 20
million.
It's going to be tough. Three years. I'll see you guys in three.
You know, I'll give you guys each a buck. But no, I'm not going
to go over there for
not happening. I'm staying here on Twitch.
Uh, that's it. That's it. I'm a Twitch. I'm also banned because
Aiden Ross or some I don't know. But yeah, now you guys know.
No, no, that's not real. That's not real. Aiden Ross doesn't
control the moderation on kick. That's just to just to be clarificated.
I I will not You guys already know I'm not a uh not a fan of
some of the owners over there. You know what I'm saying? Like
it was rough. Okay, so now that that's over with, that's all
I wanted to say. Um I'm Yo, Direct, thank you for the sub. I
appreciate it. Um,
you think they'd want you a kick? Probably not.
But I mean, like, I think the Of course they would. Misc's still
a big streamer. Miz's got a super dedicated community. Yeah,
we we don't hate Miz here.
We We like making fun of Miz, but we don't hate Miz, okay?
We don't hate Miz at all. Ultaming thing is probably what you're
asking for. Whatever the going on with OTK, I I'm not They're
doing it. Let them do it. I don't really care. It's not my life.
It's now or never. Yo, people are messaging me nice things. Why?
Why are they messaging me nice things? What should I do?
Because I'm not going. Listen, chat.
Kind of like how you love Dan. No. Like legitimate love for Miskf.
Dan's very mad at me, by the way. I wouldn't be shocked if Dan's
going to like Dan is very not happy. Okay.
NMP was saying Miskf has been viewbotting. Do we have tweets
for that where the Miskf versus uh NMP stuff? I've got other
things. Oh, yeah, we do. Okay. No, I got it. I got it. I got
I got it. I grabbed that tweet. I grabbed that tweet. Okay, bro.
There's one thing I've always
Oh, just like I was thinking like, man, he's like, "Somebody
said have a nice day to me." What's wrong? What's wrong? Why
did somebody tell me have a nice
Okay, we got it. We got it. We got it. There's one thing I've
always been very honest about with myself and you know it's damn
true. I love to entertain. I live for you guys. Do I have enough
money? Of course I do. Like I don't like I love what I do. Okay.
I love what I Why is Dan Matt? Because I sent Nicholas Doro that
clip and it's like it's very funny because I sent Nicholas Doro
a clip that he identified explicitly what was said in it. I sent
him the exact clip and Dan's like you my podcast. He's like blaming
me for his podcast with Willie Mack. It's like bro I Nicholas
was already at you. You podcast yourself.
Nothing I did actually did anything. Okay. Advanced Basics. I'm
not answering questions on that. Uh, sorry. Okay. I I do want
to answer you specifically because I know you are a big donator.
I appreciate all the support you've shown, but I'm not answering
questions on that topic today. So, sorry, buddy. Sorry, buddy.
Does Dan really need a backpack of two infamous people's podcast
or to be a backpack on two infamous people's podcasts? Um, I
don't think he's going to be a backpack if he's with Willy Mack.
He would be the main character there, but I just don't think
Are you friends with Nick now? I don't think so. I don't think
Nick is like a fan of me. I don't care. I'm not like uh I don't
have like an ego where if people tell me I'm wrong or if I like
lose a debate to somebody or like anything, I don't I don't like
hold it against anyone. Not that Nick did that. I'm saying that
I personally just don't hold like grudges that way.
Um I'd be fine with Nick coming on the stream still. I just don't
know if he ever will. I think he kind of is like wary of me in
every possible way. So, you know, it is what it is. It is what
it is. What the [__] going on here? Ban advanced
basics. No, I don't want to do that. Willie would be absolutely
mind on the podcast. Limitless baby oil. Okay. Yeah, I know.
Yeah. Willie Willie just would never have been able to push back
against the stuff Dan was saying. It would always been like,
"Yeah, that sounds pretty good to me, Dan."
Right. Willie Mack in my head is like goofy now. He's He talks
like Goofy. Gorch. Gorch.
That's That's where it is, bro. I don't know what to say. Wait,
Advanced Basics didn't do anything wrong. Don't get mad at Advanced
Basics. He asked a question and then he was like, "Okay, all
good. We're fine. Everything's fine, bro."
Massive. I can't do the Sam Hyde black scent for Willy Mack.
Okay, that's a little too far. That's too far. That's too far.
Uh, please don't insult Goofy like that. My bad to Oh, this passion
passion accords. Uh, okay. No, you're trying to one guy me. Unfortunately,
you've you've committed to trying to one guy. I love you, but
I'm going to go ahead with the with the content this way. What'
you say? Did Nick unblock you for being subservient to him, or
did you just do it hoping he'd accept you back into his good
graces? I did it because I like chaos and it was funny and he
knew exactly what Clippy needed and I thought it was funny. Yeah,
that's how it be, bro. That's how it be. And I'm not going to
like, how do I say Anyway, back to this. Like I uh I need women
on my stream. Does anyone know any girls that are around the
Austin or the LA area that can I have no content? I'm just trying
to make up
Listen, I don't think I'm getting back to the good graces of
Nick cuz I'm not going to I'm not going to like um what do you
call it? I'm not going to stop hanging out with Quean. Okay?
And I don't think Queen is going to stop criticizing him. So
ultimately I'm going to be platforming criticism of Nick Doro
on my stream if I have Quean on. That's basically how it is.
Like I listen, it's my guy. Okay. So like if if if that's gonna
be a problem then it is what it is, right? I have no like poor
Spencer. Spencer get Oh god. But like I love you guys. Like I
really do. And honestly everyone that says it's parasocial. I
love my Twitch chat. I love Twitch. I love doing stuff here.
I love you guys. Love the culture Wouldn't want it any other
way, you know? And if I go down on this [__] tryh
hard sevens in the chat. I have no idea what's going to go on.
We're stuck here no matter what. We're stuck here. We ain't going
nowhere. Unless a big bag comes through, chat. If a huge bag
comes through, we out. I'm telling you. Like a big bag. I'm talking
like [__] Like I'll tell you.
When are you going to go going on Stardust to do a super serious
interview? I literally I literally said we're going to do one
response and then we're moving on from this topic, right? I literally
said that. And Stardust is like, "This guy's such a he could
totally own me in an interview." Well, what are you interview?
You're not You're not like asking me for a debate on some neutral
topic. You're literally asking me for an interview to question
me about my personal life. How do I dunk on somebody who's asking
me questions about my personal life? It's so
it's like such a concept. Well, it seems like you made some bad
decisions. Yeah, well, maybe. I don't know. Why do I care about
your opinion?
For what possible reason could I care about your opinion? Any
comments on foods doing a nuke video on you? No.
Was it good? I'd love to watch it. You kind of put your personal
life out there. Did
You just told me that I was dressed a certain way and I was asking
for it. You
the food shops video is good. I'd probably watch it interview
with Becket Despite her. By the way, oh, I watched a little bit
of that Queman stream. Queman was reviewing the Stardust coverage
of some of like my stuff. Um, Stardust literally does not ever
comment on the Oh my god, why did you just remind me that Stardust
exists? Holy, I have no idea how she could feel any amount of
outrage towards Froggen Denims and Caseyron. She loads up my
VOD. She's like, "Guys, we're going to watch this." She literally
doesn't analyze a single point made back and forth between the
first debate she watched and me, the guy who debated me first
or whatever, and then uh Sunday and me. She doesn't analyze any
points. She basically listens to one joke Sunday tries to make
and walk back and goes like, "Oh, he totally lost that point
there." She is so stupid and so lazy that she doesn't actually
watch the videos at all. She doesn't pay attention. She doesn't
watch. She doesn't comment. She just talks to her chat. I was
Dude, I actually said I said the line in Queen's chat. I was
like, "This blob won't watch the content. Will not comment on
the content." I'm actually chipping the out. Okay, I'm chipping
it out. I'm chipping the out, dude. Like, she actually won't
watch. Dude, just watch the content. Stop looking at your chat
only. Listen to the content and critically engage with any single
point made. Holy,
dude. It was like Queenman trying to do something else, answering
DMs, and like free booting Stardust while Stardust literally
is just free booting my VOD. There's multiple dimensions of copyright
infringement going on. It was insane. She doesn't care. Her whole
goal is to smear you. She's not being effective at it. She's
not being effective at it at
Anyway, I I like was losing it. I was just trying to like get
my mind off of things, listen to a queen stream, just chill.
And bro,
I dude, what are we doing? How the do people watch that?
I don't get it.
That's how I feel watching you when you have one of your DM disasters.
What the are you talking about my DM? Shut the up. Evil Johnny
Bravo. I don't even know what you're talking about. Look, I'm
reading chat and interacting with chat. And guess what? The video's
paused because I have some concept of like, oh, I want to actually
comment on this. I want to actually see what Misk says. I don't
want to just watch this Misk video and then have no knowledge
for later. How the do you even stream? How the do you build any
narrative over time by watching content, understanding, and synthesizing
some new thing? How do you do that? If you don't pay attention
to the content, if you just let it run while you yap to your
chat, or if you like only if you never comment on it, if you
only ever ask or answer questions. You just play the other guy
reacting over and over, I guess. So, we get it. You're transformative.
I'm not even that transformative. I actually do the chat thing
occasionally, but guess what? Guess what my vice is? I'll just
rewind a hundred times. Okay? If I don't get a point and I'm
like, "Oh, I don't know what's happening." I will just rewind
over and over and over again and I will I'll make it take forever.
I Dude, it's not even about being transformative. I'll just I'll
make that take a million years. Okay, very easily, very openly.
It's all good. Anyway, so back to this miskip thing. I'll pull
it back 10 seconds so we can catch on to where this is and we
ain't going nowhere. I just had to go off on the Stardust tangent
cuz it's like holy. Oh, and then she wants to do an interview.
Oh, wait. I'm actually not done on the Stardust tangent. She
was like, she was watching the video that night. She's watching
me and Queen streaming and she's like, "Oh, I don't want to go
when you're like getting gunkarded." And I'm like, "Bro, just
hop on this. Just call in, right? Just call in." And she's like,
"No, no, no. Quan would interfere." And I'm like, "Bro, all you
got to do is join and say, "Hey, I don't want uh I don't want
to debate Queen. Can I just oneonone? What am I supposed to do
at that point? Am I supposed to go, "No, Queen stay and protect
me." Right? What What the do I do?
She could have just hopped on. I said one night. She didn't do
the one night and get loser just like nothing
It's over. Anyway, anyway, we continue. Unless unless a big bad
comes through, chat. If a huge bag comes through, we out. I'm
telling you. Like a big bag. I'm talking like
I'll tell you immediately. I'll say chat a big bag came through.
One of those like disguised toast Facebook. I'm out of here.
I'll tell you that straight up. I'm gone. me and uh ex Illuminati
or whatever his name is. We gonna dab it up and we'll [__]
yeah. I'll take it. Uh Saudi Arabia makes a new Twitch. I'm out.
I'm just kidding. It's got I'm I love Twitch too much. I love
you guys. I want to wish you a merry Christmas. Wow. Wow. Misk
doesn't want to do it. Okay, let me look at this uh this NMP
set of logs here. Beef of the day is heating up. This is from
July 4th. That's 5 days ago.
Msk. Miz kids versus NMP. NP throws shots while leaking. Misk
has allegedly been terminated from OTK since 2023. Worst community
on Twitch. You wonder why he doesn't get invited to anything?
He's terminated from OTK and has no say. Wait, he was in Only
Fangs. They did Only Fangs together. Nick claiming Miz lied about
his stalkers in his Discord to then get fact checked by Skitzos
is a new low even for him. Keep proving my point, Miz Kids. Y'all
are a cancer and need to move on. You're pathetic. Gossiping
about your friend. An org teammate like that is sad. Crazy that
I used to watch over a year ago. True colors always show. MP
in the big 2025. Wilting Rose. He's not in the or bro. And he
hasn't been since 2023. Bro's been lying to your face for years.
Wait, does that just mean that he's not had like a decision-m
capacity in the org? He's definitely had the Why would you Hold
on. How is that even possibly true? if he like puts the branding
up and has he not had the OTK branding up and also isn't this
a little weird for you Nick when you got like Emiru right there
who's like dating him or Emiru and Msk not together anymore or
some [__] cuz this is weird to like you now have
one of your biggest streamers your biggest female streamer on
the planet apparently although maybe not anymore she uh probably
broken up. Yeah, I wouldn't know but like I I feel like this
would be awkward. Feels like it would be awkward. Jasmine isn't
part of OTA. Then why does he keep throwing up their set? I have
no idea what you mean. Emir just hung out with Maya. She did
did some weird or something. So I saw a clip. Saw a clip about
it. Okay. He lied right to your face like he does with everything
else. There, I said it. He hasn't been since 2023. Miz isn't
Miz Oh, wait. I'm top bottom to top. Miz isn't an OTK, bro. And
hasn't been since 2023. There I said it. He lied right to your
face like he does with everything else. He's terminated from
OTK and has no say in anything. If that's the case, then so is
Rich and Schlot. Worst community. Oh, so this would be Oh, this
confirming that Rich and Schlot still have um sock in OTK. Interesting.
Interesting. Worst community on Twitch. You wonder why he doesn't
get invited to anything. Tired of Miz Kids posting about me in
their com their community.
Why is Nick so weird? But okay, Miz. So, apparently Miz was not
in OTK. It hasn't been. This is the view botting thing. Let's
go.
Bro is farming. To be fair, that miz stream was last night. He
randomly booted up and said, "Blah." Randomly live at midnight
playing a sponsored game. Hits almost the same CCV is prime time.
Damn. How does he do it? I'd love to know. Why aren't you guys
getting Why aren't you guys this dedicated? O
shade?
I see the shade.
What do you mean doubt? 22k viewers, 12k chatters. Those are
facts. You can fake both stats. Chatters isn't a good metric
to check. There there are people with 80% ratios and bot every
day. I closed your catchies and M's yours catchies and M's stream
when you all started playing. Well, my graph shows that, but
uh the viewing conversation is the most pointless one there is.
Even if you could blah blah blah. I talked to Pluto about it
and I'm going to get some slides together and get a meeting with
Dan. We'll see how it goes. This is Dan Clancy. Dan Clansancy.
Remember that Nick refuses to stream because that would mean
giving Molina more money in the divorce. Melina,
yes,
you should stfoo. Shut the [__] up,
maybe that's true. I have no idea. Molina deserves the money,
though. She helped build the product. I think people in on the
ground floor would get equity. I think Molina has like 50% equity
in that stream, basically. Unfortunately for Nick, maybe like
6040, maybe. I think you just take his viewer base when she joined,
right? when she like married him and then you just take the additions
that came in later and basically you calculate equity based on
that so they would get 50/50 from that point on right and I think
they built the primary part of their audience after she joined
they would have had a good start though before cuz I think she
he was already a famous streamer right Nick following Destiny's
path he's on dead kids also no way why bro these people just
ape political views that they don't have
why why do people do that why do people just pretend to have
political itical views. You don't have political views. You're
just copying somebody else. Shut the [__] up. $10.
Yeah, that is what it is, isn't it? It's just bucks. It's just
dollars. Dollars and cents. I'm going to check this blast off
tweet one more time. Did we get there?
We're not there yet. Uh the Discord should still be locked, right?
I think the Discord is still locked. Yes,
it is indeed.
Hopefully those people make it. What is this on kids stuff? Oh,
it's related to those Texas floods. Just using like people try
to say like, "Oh, people laughed at the California wildfires
and blame the government and so now I'm going to laugh at all
these dead kids uh being there because Republicans didn't save
them." It's like, what?
Huh?
How many How many people even died in the LA fires? How many
people died LA wildfires? 29 people died in the fires across
LA. Death toll rose to 30 after humans remains were found in
the eaten fire burn zone. So 30 people uh how many
died Texas flood? 120. So 4x I thought it was more. And also
I think the tragic thing of this is like the um there was actually
like a group of kids, right? There's like a summer camp that
was there,
right? It's like there's kids in a summer camp.
160 missing. Jesus.
Jesus. Republicans. Wait. Okay. Also, that doesn't mean you should
say that doesn't mean it's good to laugh at other people dying
either. It's it just doesn't and it's like it's not even about
civility to like your political opponents, but civility to the
people who died who didn't make comments.
Right. This I said this by the way. I've retained this position
forever. I say it's cringe to celebrate a dying. I say it's cringe
to celebrate the queen dying. It's cringe to dance on the graves
of kids because your political opponents might have danced on
like some gay people's graves in LA. It's so stupid.
Um, and listen, you can you can do it, too. And I don't even
think it's evil. You can do it. But at least be
At least be funny.
Don't just don't just be like, "H, those kids died. You suck.
Republicans suck."
It's goofy. I don't know. It's just goofy. Anyway,
what else do we have here? I was going to comment on these guys.
These are what we were looking at next. So, Teone says, "Misk
doesn't have any friends in 2025. Claims he was never a friend
to him, though he tried 3 years ago. I want to make this very
clear. I'm not friends with them at all. Tried, but it didn't
work like 3 years ago. I like friends who treat me well." Oh,
boy. Kids, y'all are in cancer and need to move on.
Okay, I'm going to let this play. I'm going to grab a drink and
then I will I'll be right back. Okay, I'll be right back. Let
it play and then I I have to do some analysis.
Also, is the music loud or is the music at the right level for
you guys? You tell me. I'll be right back. Keep proving my point,
Miz Kids. Y'all are a cancer and need to move on. Honestly, true.
Uh, you're a pathetic gospel about your friend and or teammate.
Like, that is sad. Yeah, I don't really think anybody's actually
friends with Miz, to be honest. Yes, at least not in 2025.
Yeah, I don't really know anybody.
Yeah, that's okay though. It doesn't matter. Uh, but I do like
how people always say, "Hey, nice what you're saying about your
friend." I want to make this very clear like
I'm not friends with him at all.
I tried it didn't work like three years ago.
Um, but yeah, I like friends who treat me
Right. That's pretty much it. Uh, keep proving my point, Miz
Kids. Y'all are a cancer and need to move on. Honestly, true.
Uh, you're a pathetic gossming about your friend and or teammate.
Like that is sad. Yeah, I don't really think anybody's actually
friends with Miz to be honest. Yeah, at least not in 2025.
Yeah, I don't really know anybody.
Yeah, that's okay though. It doesn't matter. Uh but I do like
how people always say, "Hey, nice what you're saying about your
friend." I want to make this very clear. Like I'm not friends
with him at all.
I tried. It didn't work like three years ago.
Um, but yeah, I like friends who treat me well, right? That's
pretty much it. Uh, keep proving my point, Miz Kids. Y'all are
a cancer and need to move on. Honestly, true. Uh, you're a pathetic
gossiping about your friend and or teammate. Like, that is sad.
Yeah, I don't really think anybody's actually friends with Miz,
to be honest. Yes, at least not in 2025.
Yeah, I don't really know anybody.
Yeah, that's okay though. It doesn't matter. Okay, did you guys
get that now that it's looped like four times? Sorry. I went
to go fill up a drink and my glass shattered in my hand. My glass
literally shata It's a crystal glass, so it like broke and like
shattered. I just I set it down like too hard. It had like a
slight crack in it, so it just broke. So, I was like going to
get a drink and it like started spilling. I like didn't even
realize before I filled the drink up. Did it cut you? No. No.
No. Like it just a piece like broke out. I didn't even realize
it. And then I went to go fill the drink and it like started
draining out of the bottom. Jesus.
Anyway, yeah, I'm good. I need to find out where that glass went.
I like started I started like to pour that drink into another
glass and then I'm like, "Oh, I don't know where the glass is."
So,
anyway,
okay. So, nobody likes Miz. Nobody's like Nobody likes Miz anymore.
Nobody's friends with Miz. Damn. Teto makes a comment.
Asmin Gold is going to react to that exact comment. Let's see.
Let's see. I wonder if I should go get more context on some of
these things, too. Just because like now we got Asmin Gold making
the comment and I feel like there's going to be more before after
this, right? Probably.
I know. You guys don't know yet. Oh, so gay. So gay. Vague posting.
Very Oh, man. I guarantee you, bro. Like, they've been crashing
out on each other for a while. People are going to be saying
some [__] about each other in a bit. I I I will I
will say this.
If any of these guys drop receipts on each other and anybody
lies or misrepresents
anything, I will be there to correct the record.
As Gold's going to call balls and strikes, balls and strikes.
He's going to be very fair. He's definitely not going to take
the side of the guy who's been sucking his non-stop for the past
year and a half. He's definitely going to be very fair, guys.
He will be impartial. totally not take into account the fact
that Dez Techn's been sucking him off for all this time. Absolutely
That's all I'm going to say. If anybody starts saying anything,
I will be there. So,
want a good like a like a true friend. State Farm is there, guys.
And Asminold also. Yep. We need a good clean fight. No one no
below the belt shots, no lying, nothing like that.
And uh yeah and and so we got to yeah I I got to be I listen
somebody got to do it right and so uh that's it.
The mad prophet as gold. Well the thing is that can tell us a
few hours advance. I have a meal ready. No this this
is going to go on for like a month.
Aren't these people supposed to be friends running a streamer
house at one point? They were friends. somebody in I put this
in uh discord earlier today and somebody was like oh this is
what you get for running a streamer or I'm like I mean what do
you get like tens of millions of dollars earned extra over what
they would have earned streaming
Like I I feel like all of these people made so much money from
OTK that none of them actually care that they're bitter now.
Like they made so much money. I to call OTK a failure is just
crazy, right? Like it's obviously crazy on its face. OTK, even
if they totally implode right now, couldn't possibly be considered
a failure. It's like a success by every possible measure. Do
we think it's about Amiru? Do we think it's about Wait,
what did What did Iron Mike do to Amiru, guys? What did he do?
Where Where's Technone's dad? What did he do to AmirU? Why did
he break up OTK? What the Okay, this is all fake, so scripted.
Sure, with the amount of dollars their orgs make, uh, they have
non-disparagements. Well, Miz apparently isn't in the or anymore
and hasn't been for two years. Who is Iron Mike? It's uh Mike.
Teone's dad. Guy's name is Mike. I forget the last name, but
uh Teone's dad. Teone's
father. Yes. Yes. What did he do to Emiru? And how did that break
OTK up, guys? It's micro. It It's not that. It's not that. You
thought you You thought you had me, Zan Cali, didn't you? You
stupid.
Yeah, you're a stupid Zan Cali. You thought you had me? You didn't
have me. You didn't get me.
Nope. Nope.
Not today, sir.
Continue with the clip. Minimum. When whenever whenever they
start talking about each other. Uh, that's what Ted can't moderate
this. No. And by the way,
when it happens, I want to let everybody involved know I'm not
involved with this [__] anymore.
Oh, everybody. Okay, that's actually not good. Everybody's just
like, you know what? that OTK or I don't even know who those
people are like I wasn't involved in this [__] since
23 as a gold I don't know who these people are techone I I left
they didn't resign me guys what are they all distancing themselves
from they really did they really bury those Emir grooming allegations
is it is this going to come up Miskf do it a second time did
he bury it a second time no way I don't see how it's possible
that's just me speculating by the way none of that is real okay
that's just skitso posting hoping we get some more miz kids in
the All right,
you're going on a video. It's going to be a video. You might
not like it, but it's going to be a video. People are getting
farmed, bro. Like, stay out of the drama in my opinion. Well,
this this is I I um I have my opinion on it, but I'm not going
to share anything or say anything until uh O. Uh oh, guys. New
graphic in for anything else. Uh Destiny is pretending that he
could possibly have a full beard like Pisco. Obviously, we know
this isn't the case. Obviously, we know he has excommunicated
Pisco because of Pisco's full beard situation. Okay, Pisco's
beard essentially looks like it's painted on. Desty's beard is
disgusting and sparse and falling apart, falling out in patches.
Okay, falling out patches. Absolutely disgusting.
Thank God for Pisco showing us what a beard should actually look
like. Okay, but he he stole Pisco's beard and then he put it
on himself as if that could possibly be reality. It's just not.
It's just not, dude. It's just not. Give up. Let go. Okay, this
is like watching somebody with male pattern baldness try to like
grow out the sides and comb it over. Okay, just give it up. The
beard's gone. It's It's from your younger days. Just shave it.
Okay, go back to the goatee. God has decided that you deserve
to look like a So go back to the goatee. All right, not calling
you a, by the way. I'm just saying God decided you should look
like a and he balded out your beard. Okay, that's that's just
that's just God's will, bro. You got to let that go. You don't
fight against that. All right. You can't fight fate. You can't
fight fate. You can't do it.
sorry. Back to where are we on this Asmin Gold clip? Whoops.
Whoops. Drama in my opinion. Well, this this is I I um I have
my opinion on it, but I'm not going to share anything or say
anything
until uh until somebody else Bro, there's like real imminent
drama about to happen, though. There's real imminent drama coming
up soon between Miz and the rest of OTK. Miz Teone Tech's been
kind of chomping at the bit to go after Miz if you can't tell.
His he makes it very clear to his community. Even when Misk was
big, he he would he would what would you call it? Like subweet,
okay, in verbal form. Subweet Miskf like all the time. Did Msk
get kicked or didn't Tech get kicked out of OTK? He didn't get
resigned. I say he got kicked out because he probably wanted
to resign.
He said it was a mutual thing. They said it was a mutual thing.
Nobody believes them. I'm going to be um I I I'm going to be
the neutral third party
and all I'm going to do is make sure that nobody lies.
That's all.
There will be no lies, bro. There's no way these people have
been Hold on. I need a Miz Kids stat. We need We used to have
a bunch of Miz Kids in the server that came from like the Apple
court and What are people saying? What are people saying right
now? What are people saying about Oh, wait. What is this? Wait,
what is this? Hold on. Somebody linked.
Oh, this is the wrong This is the wrong Discord. Whoops. Whoops.
Never mind. Never mind. Never mind. Resign. Resign. He did not
resign. Don't you subweet chatters in Gen Chat? Uh, maybe. I'm
saying he made his his intent obvious that he didn't want uh
he didn't want anybody to think him and Miskip were friends.
I don't I don't know what you're talking about, but yeah, you
just want to make the point clear. There certainly are some people
in my gen chat. Yes, it's entirely possible. Yais is in a bad
mood today. By the way, she doesn't like that uh Dan has joined
the ranks of the Okay, she the holoca her holocaust her 911 her
October 7th personally was the Nicholas Durio Dan Bridge burning.
Okay, that was very that was terrible for her. She did not enjoy
that. That was horrible.
So, we we should just be we should just be careful and respectful
right now. Okay, she's she's in mourning. She's recovering. Dan
was really upset. Yeah, Dan started going after Queman and then
I talked to I talked to Quean about it last night. Yeah.
Yeah. I think Dan wants to go like hard. Dan like wants to attack
me and I'm like, "Bro, what are you going to attack me for?
What could you possibly
just do my little drama stream over here? There's nothing to
even go after me for." But he blames me for his podcast getting
broken up. And it's like, dude, blame yourself.
Cuz here's the thing. That clip was not really the catalyst,
okay? The catalyst was you going on and crashing the out with
Nick Dorio on stream and he was like, "Oh, this guy." That's
who you actually you blame it on yourself for getting super egotistical
and forcing Nicholas Dioro to go, "Oh, I I don't want to be near
you right now." Like, I hope you understand as as Dan, you can't
sit there as Nicholas Dioro and say, "I really hate this bad
empanada guy so much when you do streams with Dan." You can't
it like takes away all of your like moral leverage,
right? You can't have a guy who like openly doxes people right
next to you while you're like bad is evil because he doxes people
and threatens them. It just doesn't work once Nick is Yeah, exactly.
And Nick like joined the chat and Nick like was DMing people
saying, "Hey, I need this clip. Hey, I need this clip right now."
It wasn't like I messaged Nick and was like, "Hey, you should
hate Dan." In fact, I was blocked on every platform by Nicholas.
I was blocked on Discord. I was blocked on Twitter. I was blocked
on everything,
right? I was literally blocked on everything by Nick, so I couldn't
have possibly messaged him about anything. But I think Dan thinks
I was like behind the scenes trying to get him over. I'm not
that interested. Okay. But if Nick's like, "Hey, you got a clip
of Dan saying that crazy thing that we talked about when it happened."
Yeah, I got a clip. I got a clip. Oh, don't do that, Wired Rope.
Don't do that. I I feel like if I needed a clip, if I needed
something to make a point and Nicholas agreed with it and Nicholas
was like I I think he would help with like uh I think he's got
like a professional courtesy even if he doesn't like somebody.
I I wouldn't put it that way. Yeah, I wouldn't put it that way.
Anyway, yeah. So, we can look forward to some sparks flying between
OTK, Msk,
Tekone, Msk, Asmin Gold, OTK things blowing up. Should be interesting.
I'm looking forward to it. I'm excited. Let's go. Massive dubs.
Jay-Z pulling a string behind the scenes. I didn't pull strings
on anything else today. They were watching Legal Mindset and
Dan pretended to not to know or not to know if he's a passport
bro. It was pretty funny cuz Dan does watch this stream a lot.
Dan watches a lot. I don't What do you do with a guy where it's
like, "Hey,
you engage in behavior A. I don't like behavior A, Dan, but you
engage in behavior A. I really dislike this and probably if you
keep doing it, I'm going to keep complaining about it." And then
he continues to do behavior A over and over and over again. And
then eventually
eventually somebody else is like, "Oh, I don't like behavior
A from this guy. It's like not very good." And then they're like,
"Hey, you got a clip of him doing behavior A?" And I'm like,
"Yeah, I do have a clip of behavior A." And it's it's like, "Oh,
okay." Dan Dan is like, "Oh, the guy who criticized me multiple
times for this exact behavior and now is like going to offer
somebody else a clip when somebody else is criticizing that behavior.
That's the guy I'm mad at. Not the guy who's criticizing, not
me for doing the behavior, but the guy who like gave a clip to
another guy. What? Huh? What?
I don't I don't understand it. Oh, also I meant to go back to
this techone clip and say, "Fandy, Fandy in the trenches for
Msk.
Miz has been nothing but a great friend to Brian and I. I don't
know about this take.
FY's in the trenches. Let's go." Miz got Miz got Fandy and
and Elinity on his side. Okay, we got both.
I put the Dan clip in content. Fact F. Fact F. We checking this
out. What is this? Oh, Meowies. That was cuz I couldn't name
all of the people. That wasn't even subtweeting. That was cuz
I couldn't name all of the people doing that in the Discord.
Like, this is the last place I'd come for that kind of advice,
probably.
Just saying.
Andy is a co-owner of the gym. Oh, I didn't know that.
Dan can't be mad at Nick because Nick is an Ethan.
So, you the next best target? Um, I mean, he could be mad at
Willie, could be mad at Nick, he could be mad at anyone. I just
don't understand he could possibly be mad at me.
Well, I I understand he could be annoyed, but he can't blame
me for all of it, right? It's just factually like not my problem,
not my not my fault.
Even though Dan knows he's a passport bro, he passes by, lets
it go. Let's check it out. Neither here nor there. Let's That's
pretty funny. Asan does this weird. It's just like just shut
your mouth, bro. Well, calling guy a password, bro. No. How weird
is this for them both knowing that they've both watched this
segment of the stream? Like, they both know they've watched this
on my stream, us cover it, right? They both know that. And Dan's
going to pretend he doesn't know. And Destiny's going to go,
"No, you're not going to get me to pretend I don't know."
It's very amusing. This guy, he's an immigration attorney that
helps people get visas to go to those countries. I think he likes
anime, though, so you know, I'm not going to go out too much
on a limb to protect him. I bet he's a pass. Also likes lady
boys. Also explicitly defined himself as a passport bro. Also
explicitly runs a man uh what was it? Manoververse manoververse
website for moving to Asia. Young men, escape the collapsing
west. Go east now. Go east now.
Go east. I Dude, I will I wish I could clip together for you
guys my call when I like watched him talk and I'm like, okay,
when he just said the tranquility of of Eastern Nations, the
tranquility. I'm like, that's a dog whistle for being a something.
Okay, that's a that is a total every single hair on my neck stood
up when he said for men who just appreciate the tranquility of
the East. It's like it's like okay okay. I just I felt every
nerve in my body like tense at the same time. Oh my god.
It's not my By the way, like that was the call before we had
any of the evidence in.
Can a Yan go east? Can a Yan catch a vibe to the east? Can a
Yiann catch a vibe to go east? I I don't know, man. Not without
being a passport, bro. Apparently, bro, that's what I think of
number one. My number one remembrance of the Philippines is that
it's tranquil. Isn't that what everybody knows for? Haven't you
heard people speaking the v the wait, did I say the Philippines?
Yeah. Haven't you ever heard people speaking uh pinoy to each
other or tagalog? Is it tagalog?
But uh the the whatever the the Filipino language. Okay. Have
you ever heard them speaking it? It's very tranquil language,
right? It's definitely not We definitely don't have um Yeah,
it's tagalog. It's tagalog. It's tagalog. I have friends I have
friends who are from the Philippines. I knew that. I I mixed
up words cuz I haven't talked to them in a little while. Okay,
that's all. That's all. That's all. That's all. That's all. Yeah,
Vietnamese people and Filipino people don't speak that that differently,
Resi. They do not.
You think Legal Mindset knows West? Yeah, I remember that. That
was uh his consulting. Oh, I got a whole bunch of stuff about
legal mindset. Oh, somebody sent me a bunch of stuff about legal
mindset. I could actually go into it. I could actually go in.
Dude, we could do a legal mindset research stream, couldn't we?
I think we could. But which is which sucks because I be full
disclosure. I DM' this guy on Twitter just being like, "Hey,
uh I don't know if you saw like this recent filing for the Destiny
lawsuit, but I think it's like pretty interesting. You should
check it out on your stream. You need to know anything." I could
I could give you like a second opinion if you want to know anything
like I I would help you like produce this segment cuz I was like,
"Oh, I I think we should get eyes on this cuz um Pixie's like
funding was going down, right?" Just full disclosure cuz I I
am kind of going to go after him now. I think I'm going to kind
of like cover him and if he if he pulls those receipts I would
feel bad if I didn't disclose that like yeah I did ask him for
a for like to do a segment on that stuff. So that just so you
guys know. All right. Philippines not great. Oh but he also went
to Thailand. He spent a lot of time in Thailand. He still has
consultations up on his website for Thailand.
So even worse Loki Coco for beating the beating those allegations.
I'm not calling him that though. I'm just laughing that like
he's definitely a passport bro. Why are you going? Well, I'm
not going to go after him, but like we're gonna explore his past.
Okay, we're gonna we're going to look into it a little bit. His
past in America, which is a bit shady.
A wee bit shady. It's a wee wee we bit shady. Okay. Poor bro.
I don't I've seen nothing that makes me believe that to be the
case. Look him up. Legal mindset passport. I've already No, I'm
not I'm not doing a live incrimination of a good man that's trying
to take They both They both have to pretend that they don't know.
Oh boy. Oh boy. Did he ever practice law here? He did. He did
practice law in the US, actually. He did. He did. He did. He
did.
Anyway, that's funny. That's funny. Maybe they'll just Google
it. Legal mindset passport, bro. Oh, man. Should I do uh should
I pull that lady boy mindset clip one more time? I had to use
the bathroom real quick. So, I I'll pull it. We can watch it
real quick. Ethan Ralph. Ethan Ralph. Ethan Ralph coming in clutch.
Okay. I don't know many people I wouldn't consider some kind
of passport bro who would do this who would who would say these
things. Okay. I'm going to hit play. I'll be right back. I might
be 5 10 seconds after the club right? Which I can understand
having been in the Philippines cuz I can say this and this is
all due respect. This is nothing about Lady Boy, not Lady Boy.
It's just the Philippines versus Thailand. Thailand has a more
of a sub cool attitude. You know, Philippines is way more aggressive.
Uh, special. I don't know, man. No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no. The Filipino lady boys, I can tell this in Manila, right?
And you're an expert. I can see how that was imported here are
far more aggressive than the Thai lady boys
until they're not until it changes until the ties snap and it's
like Yeah, but that's a different Yeah, true. You know, true.
Like off rip. Off rip. Well, because next thing you know, it's
it's the gangs in New York on Soy 11 between all the lady boys.
Which which was international news. everyone, right? Which I
can understand having been in the Philippines because I can say
this and this is all due respect. This is nothing about Lady
Boy, not Lady Boy. It's just the Philippines versus Thailand.
Thailand has a more of a sub. We're back. We're back. We're back,
dude.
the lady boy knowledge on this guy is crazy. What changed with
legal mindset? I've been at a funeral in another province for
a few days. Nothing changed. We've always joked that this guy
was called Lady Boy Mindset or Lai Mindset or um because he's
a big anime fan as well, but uh it turns out he he came out against
Hassan said, "I'm not a passport bro. I'm not a passport bro,
right? I'm not Hassan called me a passport bro. That's totally
fake." And then it turns out he's got a literal website and channel
where he talks about how to get people how to escape the collapsing
West to go to an Asian country. Okay? And he's got a video on
his channel where he literally defines himself as a passport
bro, but he got super mad about Hassan calling him a passport
bro and tried to correct him.
Very interesting. Anyway, I But listen, you like lady boys. We
have people on the stream sometimes who like lady boys, okay?
That's not a cardinal sin. You can like a lady boy or two, all
right? You just can't lie about it. You got to be real. Be honest,
okay? be honest about your love of lady boys and then I can let
it go. I can be fine with it. But you cannot lie about your love
of lady boys. You cannot lie to try to beat Ham. All right. Not
cool. Not cool. Thanks for the clip. Thank you. Thank you. This
is a safe space for lady boys. Wes, I beat AIDS, by the way.
Oh, we love Wes.
We love Wes. Oh, somebody I forgot somebody donated 25 subs at
the beginning of this stream. So, I should actually go like 4
hours 35 or something. I should add some extra time because if
I don't add extra time, that just looks real disingenuous. But
I got to reset the timer at the top, too.
Whoops. Hold on. Resetting this.
Boom. There it is. Somebody donated during the intro screen.
J's community loves lady boys, especially Jtock. You are safe
here. Nope, that's wrong. Although, there are a couple, I think,
in the uh the old Discord there. Okay. discord.gg/jstk. gg/jk.
Oh, also, just in case somebody thinks so, I'm not even crazy.
I'm not even criticizing passport bros. All right, you want to
be a passport bro? You want to you want to bring Okay, you happen
to meet a girl when you're like 30 and she's like 18, 19, you
want to bring her to your country and then move her to LA and
then move her to Miami and really like never let her form friendships
and have her whole career be like built around you and totally
dominate her in every way. You want to do that kind of thing?
You know, I only have like minor criticisms for you. Okay. only
like minor criticisms. The NMP strat. Well, I was thinking of
a different streamer, but also NMP. Yes, NMP possibly worse in
fact. Oh god.
Yeah, Fandy thrown down with Mizkiff. Okay. In the Great War,
Fandy all of the all of the MIL energy going to Msk. Not huge
blow to Techone. Okay. That he's lost he's lost the entire MIL
contingent in Austin, Texas. Huge blow to Techone side of this
OTK breakup drama. Okay, we'll have to see who he can grab his
allies. He's got the incelss. All right, he's got he's got Asmin
Gold's incelss secured. Gives him a massive advantage, but Miskf
is chipping away at some some cohorts here. He's acquired the
Austin Mils. We'll see what else he can do.
We'll see what else he can do. He's going to have to do a lot
of work. Okay, he's like 10 points down in the polls right now.
We're going to have to see Msk put up big numbers. All right.
really big numbers. Listen, I'll I'll I'll talk to Queenman tonight
and we'll see what we can do. Okay. Maybe we can cook up some
uh some propaganda in the background. All right. Maybe we can
cook up I mean I mean maybe we can be very honest in our analysis
in the background and see if we can get um see if we can figure
some stuff out. Okay.
That's a joke. We're always on I'm always honest in my I'm always
honest in my analysis of things. Okay.
But we'll see if we can get Misk some help. Okay. Because if
Teone's his enemy, then
Msk is my friend. All right.
If Techone is my enemy or sorry, if Tekon is his enemy, then
Miskf is my friend. That's all I can say. I may I may have had
some bad opinions about Miskf in the past. I may have laughed
when he talked about wanting to kill himself because he went
down from $50 million a year to $30 million a year. All right.
I may have laughed at him for that, but I will never laugh at
him for wanting to techone. Okay, metaphorically career-wise.
All right, I will never laugh at him for that. Also, maybe if
we can get him a win in this, then maybe uh maybe we all get
to meet Emiru. So, boom. There it is.
Uterior motives laid on the table. All right, we're going into
this. Eyes wide open. Eyes wide open. Hearts pounding. Okay,
we're we're going in. Adrenaline up. Yes.
Sorry, I'm not going to continue. I just Dude, I don't know why
my mind goes to the most insane places
immediately. Never mind. I'm I need to chill. I need to chill.
Chill. Chill. Chill. Chill. Chill.
We need to chill. We need to chill. We need to chill. We need
to chill. It was nothing to do with Emir. It was about um It's
about taking Techone down. Okay.
Not good. Not good. Not good. Naka.